families carry the few possessions they
have while they can
caught in the battles for territorial
control their fleeing violent gangs that
have taken over their neighborhoods
this is the latest wave of displacement
in Haiti's Capital Porto Prince
where gang crime is Rife and shortages
of food and other Essentials are
widespread
some seek shelter at this high school
they feel let down by their government
it wasn't gangs that chased me out of my
home it was the Haitian state that made
me abandon my home if the Asians say
that killed all the people because it's
the state that has the so-called
legitimacy of violence
lawlessness has plagued Haiti especially
since the assassination of President
jovenel muiz nearly two years ago
the UN estimates more than 2 000
Haitians have been killed in the first
half of this year as gang crime
escalates
we lost our policemen who are helping us
fight The Gangs they bled all night and
now the gangs are bathing in their blood
nearly 200 criminal gangs operate in
Haiti
more than half of them in the capital
alone
they're armed and dangerous
the United Nations has again appealed
for Urgent International Help
saying peacekeeping is no longer an
option
we hope those those efforts move as
quickly as possible in the meantime we
know very well with the the horrendous
security situation is on the ground in
Haiti and the the horrendous
humanitarian situation as well as a
result that keeps getting worse as a
result of the deteriorating security
situation Kenya has offered to lead a
support Force to intervene in Haiti but
the U.N security Council has not
discussed deployment so far
Felix noora Al Jazeera
foreign